couple of days ago on this show
i was discussing
how terrible dr fauci is and i just sort
of off the top of my head said that i
wanted every candidate for federal
office
to
sign a pledge i wanted them to sign the
michael knowles public health protection
pledge and that pledge would have to
include two things one
if you are elected to congress or the
senate you will
vote to subpoena dr fauci and
investigate him and then using the power
of the purse in congress you will zero
out his salary so you can't fire him if
you're in congress but you can get rid
of his salary
very simple just two things i pledge
that i will do this mentioned it on the
show we moved on with the rest of the
show
then yesterday i see a message from a
congressional candidate beau heinz
bohens is running for congress in north
carolina
and
he said michael i heard the show
we had our staff draft up the pledge i
am honor honored and proud to be the
first candidate to sign this pledge i
said bo that's really funny he posted it
to social media
all of a sudden a ton of different
congressional candidates senate
candidates candidates all over the
country
start posting their
photos
of the pledge and they're signing it
here it is i've got the pledge right
here in my hands
it's very simple
michael knowles federal public health
protection pledge i
so and so pledge to the taxpayers of the
state or commonwealth of whatever the
place is and to the american people that
i will one
vote to subpoena dr anthony fauci in
order to investigate any corrupt
activities to which he may be party
regarding the covid pandemic as well as
the numerous and demonstrable lies that
he has told to the u.s congress and the
american people regarding the virus its
origin and the efficacy of public health
measures to fight it and two
i will sponsor and vote for legislation
that reduces the salary of the director
of the national institute of allergy and
infectious diseases niaid and chief
medical advisor to the president of the
united states dr anthony fauci to zero
dollars and zero cents
candidate signs here witness signs here
very simple
okay a ton of candidates have already
signed this pledge
i need you i need your help
to get every other
congressional candidate senate candidate
incumbent sitting politician at the
federal level to sign this pledge i want
you to tag your congressman your center
i want you to tweet this at them i want
you i want them on the record i want
this anthony fauci gone i want him cast
out of public life i don't want him to
have any more political power in this
country i will not vote for a candidate
at the federal level in 2022 who does
not sign this pledge and you should not
either glad you like that show
ring the bell
ring it you got to ring the bell
ll ring my bell and then if you're still
not getting notifications head on over
to apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play wherever you listen to your audio
podcasts leave a five star review type
in the michael knowles show subscribe
good to go we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]